what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and we have even more
brand new Spider-Man news today but it
looks like it sounds like it's official
According to some insiders Tom Holland
has officially and finally signed a new
deal to play Spider-Man in the MCU which
is great news it doesn't sound like he
is going anywhere however the reports
that we're hearing are not just the fact
that Tom Holland signed on for another
Spider-Man trilogy but in fact has
signed on for three additional movies as
well so six movies in total now of
course we're going to be going over what
these movies could be and what their
plots could be and we'll talk about this
in more than one video as well but we
also have to address the fact that this
could be the final deal for Tom Holland
to play Spider-Man in the MCU these
movies could be the last movies that Tom
Holland appears in as Spider-Man at
least for a while because who knows what
could happen in the future 15 plus years
later he could return for a Multiverse
movie just like Andrew Garfield and
Tobey Maguire did so to say that these
movies could be his final appearance
ever as Spider-Man probably might not be
accurate but it looks like this could be
his last deal for a very long time Tom
Holland himself even said that he
doesn't want to be in his mid to late
30s playing Spider-Man still and if we
take a look back at all of the solo MCU
movies and group team up movies that
these other actors like Robert Downey Jr
and Chris Evans got none of them
surpassed three solo films and they only
went on in the MCU for so long the only
original Avengers we really have right
now are the Hulk and Hawkeye neither of
which have had their own movie we did
get the Hawkeye Series so that kind of
counts and of course he's been in the
Avengers films and unfortunately due to
some distribution rights we could never
get a hoax solo film up until now of
course there are reports that a solo
Hulk film is coming and it seemed like
She-Hulk confirmed that but we'll talk
about that later the point being is that
it does seem like this could be Tom
Holland's final outing as Spider-Man for
these six movies and it makes you wonder
what exactly are these films going to be
about and how exactly is Marvel Studios
going to go about bringing in a new
Spider-Man into to the MCU possibly
Miles Morales or Gwen Stacy or perhaps
even both because it will definitely be
really sad to see Tom Holland not be
Spider-Man in the MCU anymore but of
course we're still going to want some
type of Spider-Man character to continue
on or start after he leaves and the
Multiverse is kind of a great way to set
up a new different variant of Spider-Man
one that exists in our universe to kind
of take on that mantle with the Avengers
after Tom Holland leaves but let's first
talk about this contract the contract
seems to be for six different movies
according to several insiders like Jeff
Snyder the cosmic circus and some other
Spider-Man accounts online Tom Holland
has indeed finished signing the contract
for six new films now we pretty much
know five and if you've been following
the channel we've been talking about
them of course three of them are going
to be a new Spider-Man trilogy and then
two of them of course are going to be
the next Avengers films the King Dynasty
and Avengers Secret Wars but the order
that these movies are going to come out
is kind of interesting because we're
only going to get one Spider-Man movie
before the King Dynasty and before
Avengers Secret Wars that's going to be
Spider-Man 4. they definitely do not
have time to do an entire Trilogy before
the Avengers films come out even working
in two Spider-Man movies would be pretty
hard if they did too they would most
likely have to put one of those movies
between the King Dynasty and Avengers
Secret Wars and for continuity and
storyline purposes that probably
wouldn't work too well so it looks like
this is how it's going to go down we'll
get Spider-Man 4. this will most likely
address the events of what happened in
Spider-Man no way home with everybody
forgetting who Peter Parker was and of
course like I always mention keep in
mind people forgot who Peter Parker was
not Spider-Man so people still know who
Spider-Man is but there are big things
to address of course like will MJ and
Ned ever truly know their best friend
and love Peter Parker will doctor
strange and possibly Wong remember both
of them have already mentioned a
Spider-Man incident do they perhaps
remember that Peter Parker is Spider-Man
these are things that are going to have
to be addressed in Spider-Man 4
especially since Spider-Man is going to
be teaming up with the Avengers in the
next Spider-Man film appearance which is
going to be the King Dynasty so they're
going to kind of have to address the
whole identity thing beforehand
otherwise they'll have to spend time in
the King Dynasty explaining that in
which it seems like it's going to be a
pretty big movie and I'm not sure if
they're going to want to take that time
to explain that but then we'll have the
King Dynasty and Avenger Secret Wars and
this is where it gets really interesting
because Secret Wars I think is
essentially going to kind of reset the
MCU all the universes are going to
collide into one Universe we're going to
have a ton of different variants and I'm
assuming that somehow everything will
kind of get reset again to where the
Multiverse exists and there's a bunch of
different universes but I doubt
everything's just going to be completely
normal again so the MCU is going to be a
little bit different and possibly really
different after Secret Wars but the
coolest rumor that we've heard so far in
regards to Spider-Man and secret War is
that he is going to finally get the
Venom symbiote in secret Wars
now they tease the Venom symbiote in the
MCU in the post-credit scene for
Spider-Man no way home but rumors have
it that they want to wait till Secret
Wars to actually give him the Symbiote
because that is exactly what happens in
the comics where he wears the Venom
symbiote suit for the very first time in
secret Wars so I could definitely
appreciate a comic accurate story but if
that does happen that means that
Spider-Man 5 is going to be about Venom
and if they stay true to Comic accuracy
Peter Parker will obviously realize that
the Venom symbiote is not that good
he'll get rid of it and the Symbiote
will find Eddie Brock but at the same
time Kevin feige the president of Marvel
Studios doesn't like to do things that
have already been done before he likes
to shake it up which is why I do think
that him getting the symbiote suit in
secret Wars is pretty cool we haven't
seen that yet but will the next movie
have Eddie Brock in it that will remain
to be seen I think regardless he'll
eventually shake the suit and end up
fighting somebody who is wearing the
suit AKA Venom and I think that's pretty
much what Spider-Man 5 is going to be
about but if this truly is the final
deal for Tom Holland and the MCU like he
said he doesn't want to play Spider-Man
into his late 30s then that means sadly
Spider-Man 6 will most likely set up a
new Spider-Man now like I said there are
six different projects that apparently
he is signed for so one is unknown there
are conflicting reports right now
stating whether he could show up in
Daredevil or not one report that is
coming from the cosmic circus which
seems to be pretty accurate is that we
won't see Tom Holland show up in a
Disney Plus show this means he'll most
likely show up in another movie but if
this is truly Tom Holland's final deal
I'm assuming that Spider-Man 6 would
probably be his goodbye his own movie to
say goodbye in if Marvel is doing a
Young Avengers movie that we haven't
heard about yet he might show up there
there's also some rumors going around
right now again just rumors that he
could show up in the Fantastic Four
movie regardless of what movie he could
show up in I don't think that would be
his final appearance I think his own
movie would be the final appearance so
Spider-Man 6 should set up a new
Spider-Man in the MCU and right now most
people I think are thinking Miles
Morales especially after the teas and
Spider-Man no way home where electro and
Andrew Garfield Spider-Man were talking
about how there's gotta be a black
Spider-Man out there and after all in
Spider-Man no way home we did see Feast
where Aunt May worked at where Miles
Morales has volunteered at and plus not
to mention in Spider-Man homecoming they
pretty much dropped a huge Miles Morales
Easter egg by showing us his uncle
Prowler and he even said he's got a
nephew that lives out here confirming
that a Miles Morales does exist inside
of our universe so that might be the
direction that Marvel goes after Tom
Holland Spider-Man not going with a new
Peter Parker but with Miles Morales
which I do think would be the right move
so it looks like Tom Holland has signed
a new deal and it might be his last do
which is sad but I'm excited for these
six new films that Tom Holland is going
to be in as Peter Parker Spider-Man so
let me know your thoughts about this
news in the comments down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos for live updates you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching wolf wolf